it's really crazy it's a I was shocked I
know she's a fighter and I love her star
share their well wishes for demi lovato
after she was hospitalized for a drug
overdose and then please forgive me for
the drink spilled on the floor ET spoke
with meghan trainor and DJ khaled at the
season 2 finale of the for both artists
who have worked with Demi in the past
are sending her lots of love I saw that
you actually tweeted we love you what's
going through your mind about that I
didn't know it was that bad and you kind
of feel like oh my god I wish I was
there for her more I wish I knew her
team better and could reach out right
away or but I just didn't know what to
say so I just said we love you and cuz
it's just it's hard bring it for her but
also her whole team and her family and
everyone around her it just must be such
a shock for them and what they're going
through so I just hope they're all ok
and I hope she's okay right now in the
hospital I got so lucky I got to sing
with her other Grammys and so we like
made a crazy connection there and but
she was sober back then and just happy I
didn't know it happened like this I know
that you toured also with Demi Lovato's
have you reached out I reached out to
her management I want her to know thank
you so much for being you because I seen
all the great things she's done when I
was on tour with her talking to kids and
telling her stories to her music and
personally backstage she would talk to
him backstage right and I went to one of
our sessions and it really touched me
and really got to know her and I told
her I said man sometimes people who got
to go through certain storms so they
could tell other people not to go
through him and but we want you to
overcome the storm and never go back to
them storms and I'm praying for I know
she's gonna be great because God is
right and I want her fans and everybody
that knows her bring that positive love
energy soul can reach to her because I
know how much love can make you feel
good and let's overcome this
let's keep winning but right now it's
about you getting some rest taking care
yourself and we love you and I know
you're gonna be I
[Music]